the inquiry team has undertaken a number
as I said of dash cam and CCTV and ring
doorbell footages
this has allowed us to eliminate
any Trace so far of Nicola having left
the Riverside which is really important
so we believe that Nicola was in the
Riverside area and remained in the
Riverside area
we remain open to any inquiries that
might lead us to question that but at
this time
we understand
that she was by the river
our main working hypothesis therefore
is that Nicola has sadly fallen into the
river
that there is no third party or criminal
involvement
and that this is not suspicious but a
tragic case for missing person
this is particularly important because
speculation otherwise
can be really distressing for the family
and for Nicholas children